this is a production of Cornell
University
thanks I'm honest so thank you everyone
for coming here today Johanna said this
is what I've done for the past I guess
maybe four years out of the past six
years that have been here and and it's
basically looking at the influences or
impacts of applications of bio even
though coming through humans originally
black carbon and landscapes and again
this is in western kenya mostly so just
as an introduction I want to just frame
some of the nomenclature here because I
do skip around a little bit depending
upon the application so pyrogenic carbon
this is carbon that has been derived
from the process of pyrolysis and and
this is more of an overarching name for
a bunch of different types than of
biogenic carbon and so within pyrogenic
carbon I'm defining things based upon
their intentionality so then biochar is
pyogenic carbon that is intentionally
manufactured for agricultural purposes
and then charcoal then of course is
pyogenic carbon that has been
intentionally menya factored as a solid
fuel and then you'll see often pyogenic
carbon is also used with as black carbon
in some of the literature but in this
case we want to differentiate maybe some
of the suits and aerosols that are often
encapsulated within black carbon and
remove those and soap our genetic carbon
is basically those minus the the sips
and aerosols so as part of the other
introduction so we've seen there they've
been quite a lot of publications and and
instances of applications or pyogenic
carbon influencing crop yields often
positively influencing crop yields so
this one comes from ever they're really
famous sites down in Brazil the Terra
Preta this one here comes from us in in
Kenya of course looking at beans and
then legumes and then another one this
is what I did for my masters and a lot
of you might know some of the work that
has come out of this department with the
chrono sequence project in western kenya
also looking at applications of biochar
and impacts with crop yields however a
lot of the mechanistic oil before I get
to that point so here's a nice graph
looking at
then biochar publications over the past
about decade or so and so just for
reference my initial coming into Cornell
was until at an eight so this is about
the annual publications in batch are and
over the past couple of years it's
really grown exponentially so the
knowledge is being built rapidly you
know every year but despite that there's
there still tends to be a lack of
mechanistic approaches to biochar and
pyogenic work in the published
literature so we have these large
implant influences in crop yields and in
some environmental impacts but we don't
really understand what's really
happening at mechanistically on the
resist here and so what are the things
that I'm hoping to do with this
presentation is to look at the
mechanistic responses of biochar to
biological nitrogen fixation and then
following that if we get some positive
responses what are the implications for
moving to intentionally applying biochar
or other pyogenic carbons at the larger
scale across the landscapes and so this
is also something that's really lacking
from literature and so we hope to tackle
this also by looking at movements of
natural pyogenic carbon within the
landscape so moving into the first
chapter here we want to focus on the
individual components within biochar
then how that will affect biological
nitrogen fixation in tropical soils so
some of the impetus for this project was
that there's been one really nice paper
that came out a couple years ago looking
at the impacts between biochar
application and biological nitrogen
fixation however this really this is one
of the only studies that you can find in
the literature looking at this and then
the mechanisms are not really known in
this paper by Rondon they tend to tie it
to nutrient application or nutrients
that were in the biochar in the minerals
and that may be influenced nitrogen
fixation but it was really left as a
black box and so uh this is a nice graph
that that looks at the different
biochemical and chemical constituents
within biochar so
we we now are more aware that voucher is
it really a specific thing it's more of
a continuum of processes and products
depending upon one would be the relative
proportions of individual biomolecules
and the feedstocks and so here we have a
more famous cellulose crystalline
cellulose and then amorphous lignin so
this is in the unprocessed feedstocks
and then these proportions are of course
change depending upon what kind of
feedstock we're talking about and then
once we pyrolyzed them so the paralysis
then intensity so that basically the
temperature increasing here on the
x-axis when we move across the paralysis
intensity we get a really a change in a
fundamental rearrangement of these
materials and so if we look down here we
have on the top part this this white
area is the pore space this gray area
the small little gray bar here then is
ash content so this would be minerals
calcium magnesium potassium silica
etcetera here this medium gray in the
middle is the volatile material at the
very bottom is what's called pyrogenic
carbon or fixed carbon and this and
these three things change the
proportions and relatively relative to
each other change as temperatures
increase and typically the limit for
what we apply intentionally to
agricultural fields would be when we
around 300 degrees Celsius and towards
the maximum would be around 600 degree
Celsius and so these are what we would
typically think to be or relatively good
char's or have biochars that would have
a positive impact in in agricultural
productivity so we wanted to do then we
wanted to see how each of these
particular components of the biochar one
would affect the biological nitrogen
fixation and how we could manipulate
these depending upon feedstock become
dependent on pyrolysis intensity and
also depending upon maybe some post
treatments and so some of our hypothesis
or that one the fertilization response
from the ash minerals going into the
soil from the biochar would only be
partially responsible for some of the
increases in biologic
nitrogen fixation our second hypothesis
was that the volatile material of the
biochar will stimulate some of the
responses in the Rhizobium so we did
this in a greenhouse experiment and this
was conducted in Kenya the soil that we
used was under long-term agricultural
production for over a hundred years was
an ulta saw with relatively no nutrient
content but the pH was just slightly
acidic at 6.1 we used a bean variety
that came from seeit that was sensitive
to nutrient responses in the soils and
it was also had a nitrogen ovulating and
non non relating Iceland so we're able
to partition out the amounts and
quantify of the biological nitrogen
fixation then in this case we used the
native rhizobium so we did not add an
inoculant we use whatever was in the
soil and we added biochar at the
equivalent rate of 15 tonnes per hectare
and then across all of our treatments we
added a basal fertilizer phosphorus
application of the equivalent of one
kilogram per hectare the sort of
eliminate maybe some of the absolute
deficiencies in phosphorus so with our
biochar feedstocks we chose a variety of
feedstocks that all came from western
Kenya a couple of them were woody
materials so these were eucalyptus alig
nuh and Dylan ox reggio which are both
trees in addition to that we used T
twigs so these are twigs that woody
twigs they're coming from the tea bush
we used rice hulls sugarcane bagasse
maist overs and mace cobs and for
pyrolysis intensities we used low
temperature and high temperatures of 350
+ 550 degrees Celsius and then in
addition to this we wanted to manipulate
the char's as they came out of the king
or maybe when they were in the kiln and
so we one of the ways we did this was to
not do anything at all so just take it
right out of the kalman and use it in
our experiment another one was to use
steam so we injected steam during
pyrolysis and this is the what's
commonly used the common method that's
used to manufacture so this is a black
carbons for adsorption and
and so what we what this typically does
is it blows out the volatile material
also blows out some of the some of the
volatile materials oh I'm sorry so the
steam this is used to make activated
carbons which is a subset of course of
black carbon that we used another one
was acetone so after the biochar was
manufactured we leached it with acetone
to selectively remove some of the
volatile materials and so the volatile
materials typically have a boilie or
tari consistency and so that they tend
to be more soluble in solvent such as
acetone and then finally we used HCL a
dilute HCl to leach out and dissolve
some of the minerals that were held in
within the ash components and then
afterwards with the HCL treatment we
adjusted the pH back to the original pH
of this over the biochar when it came
out of the coma then within the all the
pots we added water and maintained
everything at field capacity and then
harvested them approximately six weeks
after planting so here are some of the
first results so this is biomass on the
bottom in this medium gray this is shoot
biomass and then in the light gray in
the middle is root biomass at the very
top is nonzero biomass and we found
really quite dramatic and significant
increases in all metrics of biomass with
additions of our biochars relative to
their controls so here's moving also
with biomass but now we're looking at
the post paralysis treatments so with
results regarding biomass we do not find
any significant differences between any
of our post pyrolysis treatments now
this is different pyrolysis temperatures
we also did not find any significant
differences in biomass with our post
paralysis temperatures are with our
pyrolysis temperatures so this graph
this series of graphs then looks at the
nitrogen fixation and also modulation so
on this access we have number of nodules
and then when fixed access we have
nitrogen derived from fixation as both a
total % a percentage of total nitrogen
and absolute magnitude
two milligrams nitrogen fixed per plant
and in this case we saw a really some
significant differences in nitrogen
fixation and nodulation between all of
our biochars and between the biochars
and our controls in this case looking at
post pyrolysis treatments we found some
significant differences wherever we
added acetone we got a bump up in
modulation and nitrogen fixation this is
also true with our high temperature
biochars so high temperature biochars
gave us a stronger significant response
over our lower temperature biochars so
then we're trying to correlate what of
the constituencies within the biochar
resulted in these changes and we did
this by first looking at principal
component analysis and then we will
actually before this we did a multiple
linear regression once you took the
significant factors that were coming out
of the multiple linear regression we ran
that in a principal component analysis
and we found that nodulation nodule
biomass and nitrogen drive from fixation
were principally correlated to foliar
plant phosphorus and plant phosphorus up
tape we also found that the phosphorus
uptake in foliar p were not correlated
to biochar p so that the plants were
getting more phosphorus but this
phosphorus wasn't really coming from the
biochar so we wanted to do a follow-up
experiment to see if it could tease out
some of these complexities and and so
this is a series of tape actually one
table that will be looking at and just
wanted to walk you through everything so
on the top here we have two of the
biochars that we saw previously these
two were the ones that had the highest
and the lowest nutrient contents and so
these were dylan ox and eucalyptus
biochars and then below that we have our
controls and so we used a no fertilizer
control which we saw before and this
time we have a fertilized control which
the fertilizer we had phosphorus
potassium and also had
for nutrients that were equivalent to
the same rate that we found in the
highest biochar that we had which was d
onyx and then in addition to that we
have our acid-treated biochars for the
bow chairs that had low nutrient
contents that were leached out and we
had these at both a high native ph and a
low native ph and these are also in
comparison to the same controls that we
found up here and so on the top then of
course we have a number of magic nodules
we have nitrogen dry fixation as we saw
before and in this case we found similar
responses so where we added the biochar
we got greater greater nitrogen fixation
and nodulation over our controls and in
this case we measured mycorrhizal root
colonization and with that we found that
there were significantly greater micro
riser root colonization with added
biochars over our both of our controls
and looking at the acidic versus basic
biochar we found that the acidic voucher
still had greater nitrogen derived from
fixation over our fertilized control
another follow-up that we did is we
wanted to look more closely at the
volatile materials and the influence of
the volatiles on the native res opium or
not native reserving but rhizobium and
so we did is we took the volatile
extracts that we had from our biochars
that acetone soluble volatile extracts
and then we incorporated that into yeast
mannitol auger growth plates and then we
dropped using a drop plate method we
added rhizobium cultured rhizobium and
then grew them in an incubation
experiment and what we found was that
the acetone extracts with the
low-temperature biochars across the
board gives very poor responses with
Rizzo buell growth so we got below the
method detection limit for all of the
low-temperature biochars we found this
also to be true with one of the
high-temperature biochars so the biochar
manufactured from maist over at the high
temperature also it's a really poor
response in resin will grow but then we
looked at the acetone soluble evolve how
extracts
from the high temperature biochars
almost all of them gave us no
significant differences from the
controls so whether we added them or
whether we didn't add to them they were
the same the resumen basically did not
have any any having a significant effect
on residual growth both negative or
positive but with two of the extracts so
the ones coming from Dylan X and rice at
the high temperatures we actually found
greater residual growth then with the
control so that the additions of these
resulted in a boost in reso we will
growth so then conclusions relating to
our first hypothesis that was related to
nutrients in the biochar we found that
the biochars who the nutrients in the
voucher was important so whenever we
leached out the nutrients from the
voucher using HCl we got a decrease in
our responses but this wasn't sufficient
when we had the acidic leached biochars
these were still giving us a better
response than the fertilized only
control and then again we got greater
phosphorus uptake was with the prime
that seems to be the primary driving
variable for what the responses that we
saw but this was not correlated strongly
to vouch our phosphorus so what we were
thinking is that there was greater
responses with the mic araiza was then
leading to greater greater looking of
them an excavation of the mycorrhizae in
the soil for phosphorus and that was
then funneling into the plant ph was
also beneficial whenever we added the
acidic biochars we got a decrease from
the basic biochars but again this wasn't
sufficient so the acidic biochars still
gave us greater responses over both of
the controls then finally our last
hypothesis related to volatile material
so some of them definitely were
detrimental that we saw some of them
were neutral and then some of them
actually gave us a positive so we're not
quite sure at the moment why that might
be it might be that there they were
feeding off some of these materials or
maybe there's some sort of bioactive
molecules and their we're not really
quite sure but the you do know that that
volatile materials can't all be treated
the same
there's really a variable in a variation
in responses okay so now we're switching
gears we're still looking at beans and
nodulation but in this case we're
looking at the influence of biochar to
mediate against drought stress with
rhizobium in the soil so again our
objectives were to look at the physical
properties of biochar to increase then
water availability under induced drought
stress conditions and our hypotheses the
first hypothesis that the porosity of
the biochar provide refuge for the
microorganisms that this refuge then we
have a higher water potential than in
the surrounding soil and our second
hypothesis was that this effect will be
greater will be expressed more under
sandy soils than clayey soils so we also
did this in a greenhouse experiment in
Kenya we use the same soil that we used
in the previous experiment except in
this case we added another treatment
where we had pure acid washed courts and
and then we did sequential mixtures of
the two in this case we did not use the
native res opium we added an inoculant
so this was see at eight nine nine which
is a variety of ours obeah metro pc and
we use three different carriers so first
carry we used was raw bagasse that came
from sugarcane manufacturing our second
carrier was a biochar that was produced
from the spa gosti manufactured at 550
degrees Celsius and then this that the
third carrier was portions of the soil
that used as a control carrier for the
inoculants and then finally we used we
designed our inoculants so that the
knuckle instead we added matched the MPN
of the soils that we're trying not to
boost the total population of soil
rezuban but rather just augmented with
using this carrier and to our knowledge
ciate 10-9 had not been used in the soil
had not been introduced into the soil
before us and then the idea was to use
CI a 10-9 as a biomarker as
so that we could figure out how these
effects were working so we introduced
three water regimes so the first water
regime was no water stress and in this
regime we incorporated that knock you
into the soil and then water to feel
capacity and then we planted the second
and water stress was a little more
intense where we incorporated inoculants
we wanted to feel capacity doing allowed
it to dry for eight weeks then watered
back to fill capacity implanted then our
third water stress was was our greatest
water stress where we incorporated an
inoculant water to field capacity dried
it for a week water it again to fuel
capacity and then dried it and then
repeated this wetting and drying cycle
for eight weeks and then finally we
water it again field capacity and then
we plant it so our initial results this
is looking at biomass so shoot biomass
that is what we found is which we
expected that shoot biomass decreases as
our sand content increases so on the
x-axis here we have percent soils to
100% soil 100% sand or yeah so 0 % %
sand and this was true across all of our
water stresses we got some variable
responses with shoot biomass in regards
to the document carrier that we added in
no water stress in pure sand we found a
significant response with biochar versus
the other carriers and the rest of the
soils there was no significant
differences in the responses in our
light water stress the only significant
difference that we found was a greater
response in shoot biomass with our
control over the bogus and in the batch
our carriers then finally under our most
intense water stress on the pure soil
and then the 75% soil treatments we
found that the biochar was the one that
gave us the greatest significant
response with shoot biomass
now here we're looking at the same soils
but and water treatments but but
focusing on nodulation in this case
we've got very different responses our
bagasse gave us the most significant and
really across the board across almost
all of the water treatments greater
nodulation versus everything else out of
the control all the biochar the only
exception was under no drought stress in
the Pierce and treatment we found
significant greater and significant
differences in modulation in response to
our biochar amendment here's nodule
biomass nodule biomass follows the same
trends that we saw with nadja width
modulation bogus was giving us the
greatest significant positive responses
except for in that one soil the sand and
the no drought stress where we got
greater significant response is with the
biochar next we wanted to do is you
wanted to take the nodules and look
inside of them to see what the occupancy
was whether it was indeed what we added
it under with 899 or whether it was some
of the native strains and so we did DNA
fingerprinting and one of the things
that we found was it was really quite
difficult to get any culturable
organisms from these nodules but when we
did get them we found that there really
wasn't any significant differences in
the proportions of 899 versus the
natives with either our burgas or our
biochar treatments and what we did find
was that the actual proportions were
getting were relatively low so 0 to 14
percent of the nodules were the ones
that we added with 899 with the biochar
with the biggest ten to twenty three
percent of the nodules were or 899 so
what we take from this these tables here
or that the nodules are really dominated
by the natives not dominated by buyer
introduced screens so the conclusion uh
the biochar and porosity we did not find
this to be true the blood gas was giving
us the greatest significance
changes in rhizobium with it really
irrespective of most of our water
treatments one of the reasons that we're
thinking for this is that we didn't find
really significant differences in the in
our different numbers of an introduced
to strains so the 899 that we added to
the soil so what's most likely happening
here is the big haces is is adding a
boost to the native strains of rhizobium
rather than maintaining the introduced
trains through the drought stress and so
some of the literature that we've been
pulling up was relating what happens if
you added some sugars so simple sugars
excuse me to the soil you get a boost in
the native strains of ours opium the
biggest being a byproduct of sugarcane
processing industry it has relatively
high residual sugars so most likely what
we're thinking is that the residuals
these residual sugars are the ones their
responses are that are causing the
response in the native rhizobia in the
soil and then finally what about the
difference is the significant
differences in the biochar with the
sandy soil and so what might be seeing
here is the greater buffering capacity
of biochar we did not find any
significant differences in the pH
between the treatments but that does not
necessarily mean that the biochar wasn't
able to moderate the chemical conditions
within that soil there's been a lot of
papers that showed buffering capacity of
biochar to be really quite high and it
seems like this might be the most likely
reasoning for what we've been seeing
then finally with regards to the shoot
biomass I it seems like based upon our
previous study and looking at this study
that it might be linked to greater my
nutrient uptake or possibly nutrient
allocation through micro raizel forage
so now we're switching gears totally to
the last chapter and here we're looking
at landscape scale depositions and
movement across black carbon I'm sorry
of pyogenic carbon
across landscapes at the small scale and
also landscapes at the larger scale so
there's been quite a couple of studies
that have documented preferential loss
of pyrogenic carbon soil pyrogen and
carbon in the literature and these have
both come from agricultural landscapes
which is rumple and her colleagues in
2006 and from natural landscapes and
this was glucan berger and his
colleagues in 2008 in addition to that
there's been some evidence of
large-scale mechanistic coupling between
pyrogenic carbon and total organic
carbon on the landscapes and so here
Jeff a looked at global rivers at the
exports of pyogenic carbon and total
carbon from global rivers and found a
really strong and significant
correlation between the two however
there's really no process based linkages
between what people have been seeing at
the smaller landscapes in agriculture
and the nature and also at the global
landscapes with rivers so we wanted to
do is you wanted to quantify both the
magnitude and the pathways of
terrestrial black carbon loss and and
translocations within the landscape as a
response from initial fire event we also
wanted to see if we can take a stab at
identifying the mechanisms or these
movements within the landscape so our
policies was one that erosion would be
the dominant pathway for terrestrial
black carbon loss in the landscape and
that biogenic carbon would be
preferentially eroded from the
landscapes so we did this by using some
of the paired watershed studies that
have been established within this
department over the past couple of years
in western kenya and about if you
remember John wretched this is what he
did for his entire PhD so what we have
here is a pair of forested watersheds a
pair of watersheds that were converted
into agriculture relatively recently so
2001 a pair of watersheds that were
converted in the medium term so in the
early
90s a pair of watersheds that were
converted from the native forest in the
1950s so we were fortunate but also
unfortunate for the landscape to have
been able to monitor and evaluate the
initial deposition of black carbon in
the forested landscape so in this early
early 2012 the local population in
communities began the process of
clearing one of our forested watersheds
and then they used the woods the trees
once they were cleared to create
charcoal so what we saw is is really the
initial initial deposition what most
like occurred over the past 60 years in
these soils and this wasn't what was
classically defined as a slash-and-burn
where the entire landscape is cut down
and burnt rather it's a chop and char so
that the trees are chopped down piled
together and then pyrolyzed to create
charcoal for export in very specific
locations located throughout the
landscape so here are some of the land
use maps that we created for these
watersheds again on this panel we have
the young agricultural watersheds medium
agricultural watersheds and old
agricultural watersheds and one of the
things that would like to point out is
that the land-use change does occur and
does change between the different
conversion ages so we get a predominance
of maize cultivation here and then as we
move over time we get more and more
change into perennial crops I know that
I didn't include the key but this green
area is maize and these this this green
spotted area are is T and also some wood
lots that we have here so we took these
landscapes and we divided them divided
them into slope units so these are this
would be a summits and then shoulders
and then toast Lopes foot slopes foot
slopes than toe slopes and so we divided
these across all the landscapes and
really use this for doing some of our
subsequent analysis and so then within
these different katina landscape
positions we found we
be randomly located for different spots
across the landscapes than to sample for
soil and for other things i want to put
out that on these sides so each of the
watersheds we have we established a weir
which we took both hydrological data and
also water samples from them so across
those those landscape positions that i
showed you we sampled the soil to two
meters depth we use the cornell sprinkle
infiltrometer to measure infiltration
and erosion rates we also captioned an
erosion that we found for some
subsequent analysis and then at the
Weir's we measured by monthly stream
stream water concentrations in pyrogenic
carbon and also total organic carbon and
then in addition to that so that was the
smaller landscape across the larger
landscape we measured stream water
concentrations of pyogenic carbon and
total carbon that were in most of the
major rivers that are feeding into Lake
Victoria so these are included here in
the green for referenced our smaller
watersheds are located up here in the
red and we also measured at the only
outlet for the Nile of Lake Victoria
there in ginger and Uganda which is
highlighted in blue so in these rivers
we sampled randomly sampled five times
in one day though water from the rivers
and then we took these the 520 leader
samples homogenized them and took a 120
meter subsample and we acidified that
for transportation and then once we took
the water samples back to Cornell we
freeze dried them and then we took the
solids and analyzed them along with our
soils on a subsample under hi-pi so this
is the hydrogen pyrolysis which is a
really good instrument that can get us
quantitative measurements for both
pyrogenic carbon and total organic
carbon I've been in addition to that we
took
the rest of the samples and measured
pyrogenic carbon and total organic
carbon using fta are and then use using
the partial least-squares analysis we
did a regression to make a predictive
model for black pyrogenic carbon and
total organic carbon for the rest of our
samples so you're some of the results
this is with depth these are total
organic carbon and non pyrogenic carbon
and this really follows what we would
expect in the surface we have really
high concentrations of these carbon
species and the concentrations decrease
with depth now here we're looking at so
pyrogenic carbon and then also the ratio
of pyrogenic carbon to total carbon with
the total pyrogenic carbon what we're
finding is the same thing saw before
action this is up here where we get our
greatest concentrations on the surface
and you get a decrease with depth but
unlike what we saw before with the ratio
of pyrogenic carbon the total carbon we
found it increase in this ratio with
depth so we're getting an enrichment in
pyrogenic carbon with depth in the soil
here we're also looking at soils except
we're looking at only surface soils and
now we're looking across the different
catchments so moving from the forest to
the old agricultural landscapes and one
of the things that we see here is in the
forest we're seeing really kind of a
random distribution of total organic
carbon and non pyrogenic carbon across
the landscape within the forest of
catchments but with pyrogenic carbon as
I mentioned before we're really seeing
very site-specific increases in
pyrogenic carbon so these are the areas
where the charcoal was manufactured as
we move into the young agricultural
catchment with total organic carbon and
non pyogenic carbon we see an increase
in the concentrations and then total
amounts of these carbon species along
the topo sequence so we see a decrease
in the upper upper positions of the
slopes and we see a increase in the
lower positions along
foot slopes this was not true with the
ratio of biogenic carbon to total carbon
we're seeing is greater concentrations
of hydrogen and carbon higher in the
slope positions when we move to the
medium conversions so these are the ones
that were converted in the 1990s this
all the significance moves all this this
interaction really disappears and so we
see really a uniform distribution of
these carbon species across the
catchments and then we move to the old
conversions old catchments we start to
pick up then significant changes in
significant increases in pyogenic carbon
here again we're seeing concentrations
of pyrogenic carbon relative to non
pyogenic carbon in the higher slope
positions across the landscape this data
is there are data that we got from the
sprinkle infiltrometer so looking at
erosion and what we see I want to draw
your attention to again the proportion
of pyogenic carbon to total carbon we
don't see any increase you significant
increase in this ratio across any of our
sites from the areas where we found
really high I urgent carbon to the areas
where we found really low power jinma
carbon so this is giving us some
evidence that we are not finding
preferential erosion at perugina carbon
so here we're looking at powered total
total carbon and power jeanette carbon
and non power-unit carbon exports from
Stream waters from these catchments and
what we're finding here is that we get a
really a greatest export is happening
young in the conversion process and then
it gets a greater a greater and greater
and then after which it goes back down
again as carbon of course is lost across
the landscapes but we're not finding any
clear trend with pyrogenic carbon so our
portions of carbon isn't really changing
very much a part from this one outlier
is it really changing much across the
line
I would like to point out that the
global average for all these is around
3.5 and so i'll be using that in the
next slide so here we're looking at the
same thing so exports and concentrations
of these carbon species but then looking
at the larger landscape so these large
rivers are flowing into lake victoria
and really the main point that i want to
show here is that the ratio then the
pyogenic carbon to total carbon is
staying relatively constant with some
fluctuations but what we find is that
what we've the proportion that we found
in our head water catchments are the
same proportion that we found in the
coming out of the Yellow River so the
head water catchments were the
headwaters the Yellow River so really
we're seeing the same ratio whether it's
coming from a small scale to a large
scale of pyogenic carbon to total carbon
coming out and so again I think this is
greater evidence that we're not finding
preferential erosion of pyogenic carbon
into the landscape through rivers at the
small scale and also moving to the large
scale so in conclusion I think that the
evidence is is leading us to believe
that preferential erosion of pyrogenic
carbon is not seen across scales and we
might actually be seeing preferential
erosion of non pyrogenic carbon in the
landscape contrary to what was published
in the literature previously and we
found that these losses were greatest in
the first ten years after conversion
after which things tend to stabilize in
the system and finally this suggests
that there's low possibility of
preferential losses of intentionally
applied biochar at scale so if we were
to think about applying biochar in
agricultural systems at a large scale
across landscapes the really the the
possibility of preference or erosion of
this applied bouch are being a potential
large
monetary and time effort in getting out
there would be relatively low based upon
our data so thank you very much I would
like to thank yo hona send the rest of
the members of my committee and my lab
team for really being support of really
being a lot of support over the past
couple of years this has been a
production of Cornell University on the
web at cornell edu